how's it going bad my name is Perry back
welcome back to mad father all right
we're going back down here run woman run
run run run
yes all right now we got this key we can
go in here Nana let what are you doing
with that mouse coming don't be scared
oh you ran into a barrel gets a sense no
good animal seems to hate it ha ha give
back mom's perfume hey hey what is it
ha you don't have it where did you put
it I don't know they look around
wha-at evil that boy was with her that
was a boy oh you little [ __ ] I'll kill
all of you found a photo what is that
it's the dog all right
he needs a bone in his mouth and we
don't have one so I guess we got to look
for it if kids will ever make it through
maybe it's here
huh I should save here and let's go down
check in here hey doggie doo where could
the bone be honestly nah oh that's a
crack e I didn't see it RAM RAM RAM RAM
ma'am ma'am ma'am what a weird place to
put a bone oh I got mom's perfume thang
wha oh oh oh that was close that was
close indeed did it calm down now let it
go seriously though why the hell did it
go oh well let's use mom's perfume on
these just a little bit okay mom what
are you doing I do smile Finn perfume
maybe now I can pass the rats or
something I was I say
nice are you gonna kill me
it's doing well doing well doing what
all we did like to perfume and now I
remember good so good not so genius fit
Hey
that is creepy
ha hello
that's the same hair I don't even know
what we're doing seriously what the [ __ ]
yeah it's kinda obvious but oh there's a
crack here behind the door how do we
move the bed
huh I guess we'll have to figure that
out
oh oh whoa whoa whoa shut up shut up
hey you're not nice
do you know that no one a crow could all
right rest in the bed no I
suppressing you lamer chainsaw the bed
what if she just lays here for a while
what what huh what that is make any
sense at all what I saw the crack that
it's like why would mama mama so I can
push it oh now I'm here oh no I'm sorry
I'm sorry
damn that is [ __ ] creepy as hell
ah yay ed ma'am alright let's say
they're going in oh I can do all kinds
of things with it
I can't push it down though okay I know
what I need to do more that's yes
yes genius pin strikes again
Oh what you gonna do with a bottle of
shampoo we trap that [ __ ] ah how affect
the men no no no all right like to do
judo push yeah that's how I imagined it
happens I'm what
how can I get through that you want
shut up shut up I'm the one with a
gentle
you must keeping me from going in you
want to pass why are you getting in my
way you won't pass you one pass you
won't pass one five you imagine one by
one I will tell you why well that girl
someone's got a set you'll have to
destroy that doll if you want to go
further burn it up real good and the
spirit inside will burn real good too
and then BAM goes the invisible barrier
on the don't stop stop Dave looks like
you and I will have some fun together
that little doll okay we still can't go
what to burn it how about just put it
over those things oh I don't know
and we need to burn it somehow we didn't
check down here really I should probably
save actually nevermind it's cross tell
Harry is
ah I hopefully will find like a
fireplace here shut up kitty
oh poor kitty I'm sorry the cat is dead
well no [ __ ] whoa whoa yeah but you
gotta fight everything is happy okay so
we should be we can't oh we can't go
here crow did you see that I know they
died there's something there
oh [ __ ] not the dolls again avoid
getting in the line of sight of the
dolls does she ever turn yeah I got the
bone perfect that's what the dog needs
but we're gonna proceed even farther
just for the heck of it whoa whoa as
close guess we're going in here oh we
gotta hide in here all right
pizzas a genius he got this very well
very well
uh-oh whoa
whoosh habla de [ __ ] me shy surprising I
don't dare to go on whoa whoa whoa just
a sec right ah I can't go there this one
is turning so fast
stupid [ __ ] ha ha ha yes oh oh no oh no
oh
oh thank god I want to say did it not
see me maybe its eyes are bad
oh [ __ ] ah what are you doing what are
you doing why do you want to savor so
bad
save her and you won't be able to go
back to normal why not drag everybody
here that's way more fun yeah
stop ah what the [ __ ] who's talking is I
your crow II I'm curious about that door
knob lay a bunch of knives I'm moving
dull hollow I cool not really that
surprised
Oh what the [ __ ] is going on here
there's a knife in just pull it out
alright you're welcome and then we'll
use the Skype oh I just want to be part
of your family lame lame scalpel that
[ __ ] oh all right fine
still locked huh
what do I need the scalpel for all right
let's go here now there's something here
huh it's a key all right
something's coming [ __ ] take the key
woman aah oh [ __ ] is that Wolfie is he
gonna eat the key don't eat the key Oh
for [ __ ] sake
well I gotta Shane so this time so don't
you J I think you're gonna get away he
ate it at the key the key is gone oh
what a surprise
oh it's Shane salt I mother say say that
[ __ ] track to me god damn it
come here come here not the [ __ ] dog
I'm just gonna give you a hug with my
chainsaw bullsh a bloody table T an idea
fine soso band Oh God
die nope nope we didn't die good job
heads nope I don't know what I'm
supposed to do get going kokin save me I
did it
what am i spiced it out later
shut up I don't need to hear you scream
everything that aah oh [ __ ] now
no no croakin what have you done
okay I can't escape go
Oh just shot huh huh oh I can use the
sandbags I'm so stupid goddamn I'm
stupid
it's as they've always been decoration
don't look at me like that ah how about
that bye dad
all right I should suffice I never know
what I'm doing here
Oh nails yeah oh you're not a pretty
sight anymore oh yeah stupid [ __ ]
that's what you get for [ __ ] with
tails sub croakin oh oh barrels don't
even make me laugh rom remember oh yeah
yeah
hello-o hustles okay cool
it's it's like a jigsaw puzzle can I put
it can I rotate them oh it's fairly
simple there we go there we go there we
go too easy for pills peasy why is there
a picture of me how crazy maybe because
my dad did then this building
I drew this picture someone drew this
picture my mom ruined his picture and
we'd edit yeah
and that opened a door or something I
heard a sound somewhere
I don't even know why what's going on
carrots
I got a gap I know one of the carrots
broke out what should be there your
freak a turd man shut up cat I'd put it
back
haha you [ __ ] that's all it takes to
kill you
a carrot plant pathetic I press good
after ends up so they're by lack
imperative they enjoy this guy come over
today and I'll see you next episode
I'll buy me
all right what's going on I'm too genius
my power danger suit doing there
something ugly right now what they
annoying